do you think these large language models
can reason
they can play chess how are they doing
that without reasoning
so
you're somebody that spearheaded the
movement of rationality so reason is
important to you
is so is that as a powerful important
word or is it like how difficult is the
threshold of being able to reason to you
and how impressive is it I mean
in my writings on rationality I have not
gone making a big deal out of something
called reason I have made more of a big
deal out of something called probability
Theory and that's like well your
reasoning but you're not doing it quite
right
and you should reason this way instead
and interestingly like people have
started to get preliminary results
showing that
reinforcement learning by human feedback
has made
the GPT series worse in some ways
in particular like it used to be well
calibrated if you trained it to put
probabilities on things it would say 80
probability and be right eight times out
of ten and if you apply reinforcement
learning from Human feedback the the
like nice graph of like like 70 7 out of
ten
sort of like flattens out into the graph
that humans use where there's like some
very improbable stuff and
likely probable maybe which all means
like around 40 percent and then certain
yeah so like this like it used to be
able to use probabilities but if you
apply but if you'd like try to teach it
to talk in a way that satisfies humans
it it gets worse at probability in the
same way that humans are and that's uh
that's a bug not a feature I would call
it a bug
although such a fascinating book
um but but but yeah so so like reasoning
like it's doing pretty well on various
tests that people used to say would
require reasoning but
um you know rationality is about
when you say 80 percent doesn't happen
eight times out of ten
so what are the limits to you of these
Transformer Networks
of of neural networks which if if
reasoning is not impressive to you or it
is impressive but there's other levels
to achieve I mean it's just not how I
carve up reality
what's uh if reality is a cake
what are the different layers of the
cake or the slices how do you cover it
but you can use a different food if you
like
it's I don't think it's as smart as a
human yet
um I do like back in the day I went
around saying like I do not think that
just stacking more layers of
Transformers is going to get you all the
way to AGI and I think that's gpt4 is
passed or I thought this Paradigm was
going to take us
and I you know you want to notice when
that happens you want to say like whoops
well I guess I was incorrect about what
happens if you keep on stacking more
Transformer layers and that means I
don't necessarily know what gpt5 is
going to be able to do that's a powerful
statement so you're saying like your
intuition initially is now appears to be
wrong yeah
it's good to see that you can admit in
some of your predictions to be wrong
you think that's important to do see
because you make several very throughout
your life you've made many strong
predictions and statements about reality
and you evolve with that so maybe
that'll come up today about our
discussion so you're okay being wrong
I'd rather not
be wrong next time it's a bit ambitious
to go through your entire life never
having been wrong
um
one can aspire to be well calibrated
like not so much think in terms of like
was I right was I wrong but like when I
said 90 that it happened nine times out
of ten
yeah like oops is the sound we make is
the sound we emit when we improve
beautifully said and somewhere in there
it we can connect the name of your blog
less wrong
I suppose that's the objective function
the name less wrong was I believe uh
suggested by Nick Bostrom and it's after
someone's epigraph actually forget whose
who said like we never become right we
just become less wrong
um what's the something something is
easy to confess just error and air and
air again but less and less and less
yeah that's that's a good thing to
strive for